centrémonos Precisamente en esta
mediación a turca entre Ucrania y Rusia
que tuvo su máximo exponente podríamos
decirlo el año pasado hace prácticamente
un año cuando se logró también gracias a
Naciones Unidas que ambas partes
firmaran este acuerdo que permite la
exportación de granos a través de los
del mar Negro digamos pues vigilando que
ninguna de las partes Ataque a los
buques que se encargan de este de este
comercio le pregunto si bien
kilisaroglu Se presenta como una pues
como una posición más favorable a
occidente y a la Unión Europea En qué
modo esto perjudicaría de hecho
el entendimiento en nuevos y eventuales
acuerdos entre Rusia y Ucrania no en el
marco de esta guerra
muy interesante tu pregunta Rosa porque
sin duda Turquía le ha permitido ser un
gran jugador
pedía de mediación entre Ucrania y Rusia
justo porque es erdogan pero si nos
fuéramos a un escenario de de tener a
quemal como presidente en Turquía Pues
claro que él se distanciaría de Vladimir
Putin y se acercaría mucho más hacia
Europa en qué le afecta pues sobre todo
en que su posición geográfica le permite
a través del bósforo de Turquía que es
por donde van cruzando los barcos con
gran carga de mercancía en general de
granos no solamente es el trigo sino una
gran cantidad de diversidad de productos
que entran y salen por el mar Negro para
llegar a otras rutas marítimas
vemos también que hay que ser realistas
O sea no porque fuera que mal A lo mejor
el siguiente presidente ya con eso va a
ingresar a la Unión Europea y y va a
estar sumamente cercano de Europa obvio
Turquía tendría que hacer una gran
cantidad de reformas estructurales al
interior no solo para combatir la
corrupción que yo ya lo destacaba hace
rato sino el tema de reformas económicas
institucionales y de rescate a las
instituciones democráticas para poder
aspirar más adelante a ingresar a la
Unión Europea sin embargo como ya lleva
más de 70 años en la alianza militar
conocida como la otan le sigue
permitiendo sea quien sea jugar en
muchas bandas en muchos frentes como un
actor activo dentro del otan de hecho es
el segundo país con mayor capacidad
militar de los treinta y un miembros del
otan de seguir después de Estados Unidos
por puesto que erdogan le apostó a
desarrollar industria militar es a pesar
de esta merma económica que ya hemos
mencionado durante en diferentes
momentos rosa de tu programa
él se ha encargado de que la industria
militar sea de Gran tecnología que tenga
los mejores tanques helicópteros para
estar fortalecido en términos militares
entonces Creo yo que Turquía puede ahí
seguir jugando y moviendo sus fichas
según los intereses del otro país o el
bloque de que se trate pero eh en esta
situación tan peculiar que es Ucrania y
Rusia yo siempre he creído y lo he
manifestado aquí en fase veinticuatro en
diferentes momentos que los grandes
actores para poder llevar a la mesa de
negociación
sin duda tendría que ser Estados Unidos
por los que tiene y China
específicamente con Putin Por qué Porque
eslogan avanzó en ese acuerdo para
granos como tú bien decías con Naciones
Unidas Ucrania y Rusia pero en realidad
no avanzó más allá una vez que logró el
acuerdo o sea sí hizo sus intentos pero
una vez que Turquía tuvo la garantía de
la proveeduría de granos
vimos ya la distancia de que ya nos
involucró más entonces sin duda pues
también hay límites Entonces se abogan
hizo la maniobra de acuerdo a lo que le
convenía a su agenda doméstica pero más
allá de eso pues también se percató de
que ya no ya no puede más O sea si ha
habido ciertas críticas con respecto a
que ya no ha habido más conversaciones
en ankara para retomar la posible
conversación de mediación para un
acuerdo para paz pero vemos que más bien
estas conversaciones se han dado en
otras coordenadas que vienen desde china
Brasil o bien de de algunas otras
naciones pero ya no de Turquía o sea
vemos que ya Turquía
está ahorita totalmente enfocadas las
elecciones pasarán las elecciones Y
entonces estarán enfocados ya después a
su propia agenda pero pareciera que de
repente se les olvidó que seguía la
puesta internacional en este tablero de
pensar que Turquía podía seguir mediando
se esfumó el esfuerzo desde el año
pasado Ya no hemos visto en ningún tipo
de propuesta por parte del gobierno
Turco y veo yo que esa será la tendencia